before we start with the today's session
i'm ushavadhi i will be sharing the
session today
and if you have not seen yet the news
and
lastly bye bye and uh have a video on
one they
just was announced they won the hubbell
prize for bridging theoretical computer
science
and mathematics
lovers thank you thank you for
correcting me i started with the first
name and my brain went somewhere else
thank you um so this is a
first of all amazing recognition for the
work of two
luminaries in in in our field
and also an amazing recognition by the
mathematical community
the theoretical computer science is one
of the have been a
senior completion of mathematics in the
in the past 50 years
so today we are going to talk about
non-cdcl solvers this is the theme of
the session today
so cdcl solver have been a another
amazing accomplishment of the past
25 years i call it the sat revolution
but i've i've been on the record that as
much as the
cdcl have been successful uh
there is a bit of monoculture in the sad
community and we need to look at
other other type of solvers and that's
what
today's three speakers will tell us
about three
different type of solvers
and the first talk is by maran hule who
is talking about
such solver such solvers but a
non-non-cdcl focusing on smart versus
fast
or as some people call it a the brainiac
versus the speed demon
go for it marion thank you
um i'm excited to talk with you about uh
look hat solvers
look ahead was actually the topic of my
phd thesis
and it is something completely different
than cdcl
although it's not as powerful as cdc on
the industrial instances
it has quite some also applications and
some interesting reasoning
and i gladly want to kind of go over
some of these
cool techniques with you
this talk will focus on on four parts
first i have a kind of a rather large
introduction
uh on softbot focusing on on look ahead
and i think um the most cool thing i
think of look ahead is actually the
so-called local learning aspect
and frequently when i see other papers
now about look ahead
they kind of ignore this aspect there's
lots of
cool local learning that one can do
and i kind of want to kind of go over a
handful of these techniques
and at the end of this talk i want to
kind of show
how look ahead can be used in
for very hard and challenging problems
in combination with cdcl
which is known as cuban conquer
marcia already mentioned this and i
guess most of the audience is very aware
about this subtle revolution the
enormous breakthrough that we had in the
last 20 years when solving sod
up till the mid-90s we were only able to
solve formulas with up to say thousands
of variables and
thousands of clauses and today we can
solve
many problems arising from industry with
millions of variables and millions of
clauses
if you kind of look back to the early
sot research say the first 40 years of
such
research so from the late 50s till the
late 90s
it was all based on dpol and let me kind
of
because that is actually also one thing
that most jordan told me
if you want to build an algorithm
you have to kind of decide whether you
want to focus on being smart
or being fast and typically you cannot
do both
because the data structures don't allow
you if you want to do something very
smart
you need very detailed data structures
and it prevents you from being fast
once it comes to satisfiability you also
actually have a second choice
you also have to decide whether you want
to focus on finding a solution
or trying to prove whether no solution
exists
and if you kind of summarize to say the
first 40 years
so the late 50 late 50s to the late 90s
in stop solving then almost all
approaches were focused trying to be
smart
and trying to find a solution and
um i think the the main breakthrough
actually came
when the people decided okay uh let's
try to be fast
and try to find to refute the formula
and actually
a satisfying assignment is just a
counter example that no such reputation
exists
but there actually has been a lot of
cool work in those 40 years and also
later
um that are
already worth exploring and also have
have their own applications
and so this is most of most of that
group to actually look ahead and i will
talk about this now
so first very very short what does look
ahead
look ahead what it tries to do is it
tries to make
a binary search tree of the search space
and it tries to make the tree as small
as possible how does this work in each
node of the search tree you pick a
variable and then you split it into two
nodes
one where the variable's assigned to
true and the other one where it's
assigned to false
picking the right variable for the split
is a very
important and can reduce the
the search tree sometimes by orders of
magnitude
this approach with the right heuristics
is very effective on
a broad range of problems although all
of them
tend to be relatively small
say up to thousands of variables and
thousands of clusters
its main weakness because the heuristics
are very
effective however they are also
expensive and if you deal with variables
over
formulas with say a million variables
this is
completely impossible because these
things are just too expensive
cdcl most of you probably know at least
the basics of
it it is not trying to be smart
as in as look ahead picking the right
decision all the time
but it tries to be fast and
so what it does it does very cheap
heuristics to pick a variable
and then assigns it simplify again a
simple
decision and only the reasoning starts
to really kick
in once you hit the conflict this
conflict is
turned into a clause which is added to
your database
and we continue right this has been
very effective on large problems which i
call
easy because sometimes the runtime of
the cdcl solver is
is linear even in case for unsatisfiable
ones
this is only possible if these problems
are easy
right so there are short proofs for
these formulas and cdcl
really knows how to quickly find them
one of the main weaknesses of cdcl is
that it's very hard to paralyze
but i will actually at the end of this
talk talk about how we can combine
localhead and cdcl for some
effective parallelism
something i briefly want to touch is
local search
local search is another solving paradigm
which is quite effective on a range of
problems
it starts with a full assignment and
then
it starts flipping the true values of
some variables
until satisfying assignments is found
some problems that take
years with both cdcl or
look ahead or that combination can be
solved sometimes in seconds with local
search
local search has the same as property as
cdcl it's all the data structures are
really focused on trying to do things
fast
um so although most of uh
the people that heard about sata are
aware of these
extremely important progress on
industrial instances
but also in the last couple of years
there have been a lot of progress
in solving long-standing open math
problems
using a combination of look-ahead and
cdcl
and without these this combination it
would be impossible to solve these
problems
efficiently
now let's go a little bit more into
detail how uh
lookahead works so look ahead is based
on
it builds a dpl3 which dates back to the
early 60s and i already mentioned it
it in it builds a binary search tree
and in each node of the search of the
tree
you pick a variable which uh ideally
splits the space into
two much easier subterms
and at each step of the recursion you
first simplify the formula
with unit propagation you can also do
some additional stuff
and and then you do a split
and this this you repeat there are two
important heuristics here
the first one is which variable do we
pick
at each note in the third of in the tree
and the second one is which of the two
branches
are we going to explore first
if you always if the formula satisfiable
and you pick
the right one you would just straight
walk to
a solution so it can be very beneficial
to spend
some time to to figure out which
branch might be the more satisfiable one
and
although i won't talk about it in this
talk because uh
it's only 30 minutes but you can do all
some
uh interesting ways to jump through the
search space or
through the tree to find the solution
fast using
uh look ahead techniques
a very simple example so on the slide
there is
a formula with five clauses
if you would pick in this example x3 as
your first decision
then you have a small three with only
two leaf nodes
however if you for example pick a
variable x2
then the number of leaf nodes doubles
and so on this small example you see
that just picking
the wrong variable doubles the size in
practice
for heart problems it's picking the
wrong variables can actually result
in trees that are orders of magnitude
larger
compared to picking the right ones so
it's very important to pick the right
variables
in this in the to for the split
i already used the word look ahead now
uh
several times and most of you probably
don't know exactly what it is so let me
be very brief on
to give first a high level thing here
the look ahead shots over is a dpol soft
solver
where looker heads are used to pick
the var the decision variable and what
is a look ahead
a look ahead is you pick a variable
assign it to a true value
and then simplify it as much as possible
this is typically only done by unit
propagation
and then you do two important things the
first thing is
you measure the reduction and
there are many ways to measure the
reduction for example you can measure
the reduction of the size of the formula
the number you can the reduction in the
number of variables i will
briefly talk about this more on some
later slides
and then what you can also do and what i
what i figured out in the in the last
kind of decade
uh is that possibly the most important
thing
what you can need to do afterwards is to
learn as much as possible
and the learning that is here is
completely different than cdcl
and this is what i call local learning
and
most of the middle part of this talk
will be on
local learning techniques once you've
finished
the local learning then you backtrack
and you do a look ahead
for another variable
yeah so this is the high level steps of
look-ahead
now let's look at an example so on the
bottom of the slide you see
a formula f learning
and i will use this formula throughout
the remainder of this stock
and how does a lookahead work so we
start
by picking a variable in the truth
assignment for example
x2 and false and so we assign
x2 to false and what you see now here is
that
this clause becomes unit
all the literals except for one are
falsified
and so you are forced to make x1 false
this in turn makes this a unit clause
and therefore forces x 6
to be false as well and now
this clause becomes unit forcing
x3 to be true
afterwards there's no simplifications
possible anymore
and so that part of the look ahead is
over
but now we need to do the next step
which is
measure the reduction
so on the next slide i will show you
this and then we will talk a lot about
learn if possible
now so this is exactly the same formula
and the assignment
of the look ahead on the prior slide and
now the question is
how are we going to
do the measurements so one way
is for example is to count the number of
satisfied clauses
in this case we have eight clauses and
seven of them are satisfied
so there's a lot of reduction if you use
that metric
you can also look at the number of
implied variables in this case this is
three of them
the number of satisfied clauses is tends
to be a very bad metric
the number of implied variables is quite
a bit better
but the best method map typically in
practice
is to count and actually weigh
the number of new clauses and new other
clauses that are
reduced but not satisfied in this
example this is only the clause x4 x5 or
x6
this one has been reduced from a ternary
clause to a binary clause
and what you do in look ahead typically
is you count the number
of of reduced clauses and then
make the shorter clauses more important
and actually you also
put a lot of weights in there and the
weights you can
maybe view as what is the probability
that the random assignment would
satisfy the uh the reduced clauses
and the uh and this heuristic
is uh is now used in most of the
state-of-the-art softwares
you do some weighing of the
reduced clauses so now we have all
aspects
of the of the look ahead architecture
which is on the top
we have we built our dpl3
and in each node before kind of deciding
which is the decision variable we look
at the simplified formula
and then we do look ahead on all the
variables or subset of the variables
and the look ahead is we assign it to a
truth value
simplify the formula and do some
measurements so for example
the numbers over here show for example
the reduced
not satisfied clauses and these are the
heuristic values
and then we need to combine them because
you
pick a variable and not a literal and
the best practice is actually to just
multiply these numbers
and the highest multiplication is the
one that you
pick but notice here
is that if you do a look ahead sometimes
the look ahead can result in a conflict
so if we assign
x3 to false it can result in a conflict
which means that all satisfying
assignments must have
x3 to true and this is actually this
the kind of easiest way of local
learning
and local learning is very important to
pick the right decision and so although
we can compute these values
in the first kind of iteration over all
the variables
it is very important to first do a lot
of local learning
which improves the accuracy of the
heuristic which in turn makes the tree
much smaller
okay now let me focus on the local
learning
so we all so what ctcl is doing
is it hits a conflict and adds a
clause to the formula and this clause is
logically implied by the formal
lookahead is not doing any of this kind
of global learning
the clauses that are added are only
valid for that
note of the search and all its children
and so what we're going to do is we're
only going to learn clauses typically
units
and binary clauses that are valid for
that note
and everything below it
and because they're only valid at this
point in the search
it means that if as soon as we backtrack
we have to
remove them all
and this also makes the data structures
much more complicated because you need
to do a lot of accounting
which clauses are valid where
let me first talk about the easiest part
and we already talked about it which is
the filter rules
so we do a look ahead on l was true if
it results in a conflict
then we know that l has to be false and
all for in all satisfying assignments
if both the look ahead on l and the look
at or not l are for
our are filled naturals then we actually
found
a dead end situation and that note is
and we need to backtrack this notion of
field literal can also be generalized to
the so-called double look ahead and
double look ahead is we actually pick
two variables and two truth values
and then do unit propagation and see
whether they result in a conflict
for example our learning formula
we assign x4 to false x x
6 to true and then by unit propagation
x 1 has to be true x 2 has to be true
x 3 has to be true and then we have
our falsified clause
and this means that we can learn the
clause
x4 or not x6
look this double look ahead is very
can be extremely effective on some
problems but
notice that this is very expensive right
because we
need to pick two variables so the
complexity of doing it
for all possible assignments for two
ones
is cubic because also the unit
propagation
is can be linear in the number of
variables
so it can be very expensive but for some
problems it is ignore a
very effective but for others it's
extremely costly
[Music]
so jacob let me let me do the
what is the question uh it's obvious why
we cannot
learn probably a globally valid clause
yeah so so jacob mentioned that of
course the locally learned clauses we
could add them as globally once by
putting the prefix in there
but at least in practice so oliver
implemented this in his soul for the
okay solver
but in practice this is not very
effective so the clause is typically
because you pick the right decisions
that
they're no longer valid elsewhere
now let's talk about another
local learning technique which is called
hyper binary resolution
so we have a variable x prime
that occurs in many binary clauses
and it occurs there with the literals
not x1 to not xn
and we also have a long clause x
or x1 to xn
if you're going to look what happens
with unit propagation that if we make
x prime false then the unit clauses all
propagate
x 1 to false x 2 to false x and to false
and afterwards the long clause becomes
unit
because all the literals x1 to xn become
false
which forces x to be true
right so if we have this situation then
we we observe that not x prime implies
x
and this happens by unit propagation but
the interesting thing to notice here
is that if we make x false
then just the long clause would
reduce to a clause just one shorter and
there's no unit propagation
and so what hyperbinary resolution does
is it picks all these binary clauses and
the long clause
and by resolution merges it into a
single step
into a binary clause x or x
prime and after adding this binary
clause
we have x not x in
implies x prime
and we're actually going to find these
hyperbinary resolvents using
uh unit propagation so we do unit
propagation
so we start with x2 and then
we have the unit x1 comes from this
binary clause
x6 comes from this binary clause and x3
comes from that binary clause
and for all of the ones that are not
implied by an x2 liter
binary clause we can add a hyperbinary
resolvent
this one or this one and
the latter one is the most effective one
because
this one so the
this one is due to a binary clause but
this one
is due to a ternary clause and would
improve the unit propagation
uh during future look-aheads
now another technique is called
necessary assignments so we do
look ahead on x is x is true x1 is true
which would imply x2 x3 and x4 to true
and now we do another look ahead with
x12 false
which would imply by unit propagation x6
is false and x3 is true
notice that in both cases
x3 is forced to true so either we
we assign x1 to true or if we assign x1
to false
we both have x3 is true so therefore
x3 has to be true in all assignments
satisfying assignments
in case we do hyperbinary resolvence we
also would find that x3 to false
would be a field literal um
but if we don't do this actually we
wouldn't find this
but doing necessary assignments is
actually
a way to find this much more quickly
another technique is
alter keys and alter cases might this is
a bit more exotic
an altar key is an assignment that
satisfies
all the clauses that are taxed by it
example is the pure literal which
there's no complement of it so if you
assign it period or true
then only clauses get satisfied also
satisfying assignment is a
alter key because all the clauses are
satisfied so clearly also all the
clauses that are touched are satisfied
interesting alter keys are the ones
actually in between
pure literals and satisfying assignments
and the nice thing that you can do
is if you find an author key all the
clauses that are touched by the author
key you can take out
and the resulting formula is
satisfiability equivalent to the
original one then there's also this
notion of the one author key
and a one alter key is all clauses
except for one are reduced are satisfied
so there's one clause that is reduced
but not satisfied all the other ones are
satisfied
now we do for example a look ahead on
x1 which results in the assignment that
x2 x3 x4 are also assigned to true
notice that all the clauses that are
touched by the assignment have
satisfied literals agree literal and
therefore the formula is satisfiability
equivalent to
x5 or not x6
and this technique can also help to
reduce the computational cost
on unsatisfiable instances a little
small side note here
is that look ahead can have can quickly
solve two subformulas by
simply doing only look-aheads you never
have to branch
either a look-ahead results in an altar
key
or and then you can force the literal to
be true
or look ahead results in a field literal
and you can assign it to false
and um yes let me because i'm kind of
um a bit short on time so let me first
um finish the talk and then we can talk
about
uh a bit more about the uh
the the aspects here that we go beyond
resolution
another cool thing here and this is
actually much more effective than
than altar keys because altar keys are
kind of rare
uh the one other key learning so now we
assign
x true to true or if it took to four
sorry
this implies x one to false x6 to false
and x3 to true
now we have a one autokey
notice that this clause is the only
clause that has been reduced
but not satisfied
yeah now the question is how can we do
any learning here right because
if we had an author key we could just
take all the clauses out
right but what can we do here
the observation here is that if
x4 would have been true
then the assignment x to false would
have been an alter key
right because xs4 would have taken this
clause out
and therefore if you would move to
excite x2 to
false this would have been an altar key
and the same holds for
x5 if x5 would have been true
then x2 to false would have been an
altar key
and as a consequence you can
learn the binary clauses the one author
key clauses
not x2 or not x4 or not x4
2 or not x5 so x4 implies not x2
and x5 implies in the texture and
the one other keys actually happen very
frequently so while the alter keys
hardly happen
one alter keys frequently happen and you
can do this
local learn right so this rounds up the
local learning aspect of this talk
so it is very important to look ahead
solvers because the local learning
really
also improves the accuracy of the
heuristics and thereby
making the tree smaller
and some of these techniques are also
used in
in cdcl solvers for pre-processing and
in-processing
now let me briefly remark some remarks
about cuban conquer
so although lookahead is not effective
on large formulas
because things are expensive you can
actually use
lookahead in combination with cdcl to
solve very hard formulas
this is what we call cube and conquer
and what does coupon conquer do
it builds the dprl tree
to some level and then for all the leaf
nodes in the dp
outreach at some cutoff level
we're going to call
a cdcl solver and
so we have we split our formula f
into n different
sub formulas the leaf nodes at some cut
in the dprl tree
and then we solve them effectively using
cdcl
and for several problems
so i've been showing this on some
mathematical problems but also some
industrial problems
we can have linear time speed ups
even with thousands of cores
and for example this technique has also
been recently integrated
in the smt software c3
i won't have time to re to go into
detail here
um but let me briefly explain what i
think is going on
because cuban conquer we frequently
witness
super linear time speed ups how is this
possible
so what how i see look ahead so look
ahead
is really good in able if so if there
are
global arguments why the formula is
unsatisfiable
then you need to make a good global
split
at some point after doing enough splits
the formula there becomes some local
argument
by the formulas unsatisfied in case
there's a local argument why the formula
is unsatisfiable you shouldn't do a
global split
because then the argument will be there
in both of the branches
and so what you need to do in order to
get
cuban conqueror effective is you split
until
a short refutation exists or at least
heuristically you expect it to be there
and then you call
the cdcl solver and the cdcl software
will find you
the local conflict uh quickly
and so the plot shows uh kind of that
you get this this speed up
uh more and more when and increases but
at some point for this problem
the splitting costs become so expensive
that the splitting is more expensive
than
than the total cdcl cost
now to conclude so i presented
some aspects of the look ahead
architecture
look ahead tries to be smart instead of
trying to be
fast and it is
tries to be smart both by picking the
right variable and an aspect that i
really didn't talk about much is
it tries to be smart by picking the
right branch
this is very effective on small and hard
formulas and also can be used
very effectively for some hard problems
in combination with cdcl
so it's important that we have these
effective splits
and a very important aspect of this is
the local learning which i discussed
something i didn't have time to discuss
is that you really need to kind of
massage your data structures in order to
do this all
efficiently but this is one of the
key things to make look ahead effective
in practice
okay that concludes my talk i see lots
of questions
more say how are we going to do this
i'll pick the last one karen what would
you like to say or
comment or ask
sure um my question was it looks like
i mean look ahead was done in earlier
solvers i forget the name of the solver
but this guy from sweden
so there's bfs and there's dfs
uh cuban conquer does bfs followed by
depth first search which is cbc health
can you view
uh this as a just one point on the
spectrum of how to combine
depth first versus breadth first and
learning in these most
different styles
um what do you mean with just one aspect
or because there's many other ways of
doing this
you you me yeah i'm saying instead of
just doing like in human conquer you do
look ahead and then cdcl what if you do
a little bit of look ahead
do a little bit of cdc l and then stop
cdcl and do more
look ahead and then do see do
cds and so on so you you interleave
breadth first and depth first
depending on what you're learning and
what's happening in the search space
yeah so we have a question let me leave
marilyn let me rephrase
maybe augment the question suppose that
we look at this this uh
the cuban conquer and look ahead it's
just another
kind of use set of we have arsenal of
heuristics
and we decide dynamically to use them as
appropriate
rather than make a decision upfront we
are going to use cdcl or
we are going to do look ahead yeah so
actually i i i had a paper i think
quite some years ago with a
student uh in delft which we which we
called
uh concurrent cube and conquer where
we had a cdcl software always running in
parallel
uh with the look ahead so we in every
note we
let the cdcl software run on the same
problem and the look-ahead solver tries
to figure out the best split
and the first one that actually finishes
kind of returns and
that was reasonably effective although
[Music]
it didn't give a major improvement
and also armen has an implementation in
tringling
where also this combination
is trying to do it as effective as
possible in practice and
triggering has been quite effective in
several of the sub competitions
so triggering well splits the search
space
lose using look-aheads but then
runs the sub-problems using cdcl
if that if they cannot be solved within
a certain time limit
all of them are split again and and this
is repeated so this is actually what
what you kind of suggested is
what uh happens in this over triggering
by i mean oh so so it's been done i mean
i'm just curious i'm intrigued by the
fact that
you know you can learn um in a local
context
something that might be extremely
helpful in you know
you know either proving unsaid or
finding a sad
and the indications of what is happening
in that part of the search space
uh could actually uh inform whether you
want to do further look ahead or further
you know cdcl again you know what you
said at the beginning which is
smart not fast you know forget about you
know being fast now but you know it's
that seems to be unexplored yet you know
exactly where you want to do this
switch from one uh uh way of doing
things to the other way
yeah but in to some extent you can also
see the in processing also as
as a bit of this right in processing
does fill literal detection and other
other things that you might do in a
look-ahead solver and so
you might kind of incorporate lots of
these look-ahead techniques actually in
an in-processing phase of the cdcl
solver
right so you don't do any of the
splitting but you only take the local
learning
part which in my experience is one of
the most effective things also
of luca head techniques oliver would
like to make a comment
may um so on this question of making it
dynamic so i think that's extremely
important
and i believe that in um
the look ahead solvers has is currently
should have a better chance
of getting a good sort of theoretical
handle on it
because so it's inherently simpler you
have all these
processes related to a tree growth
and you have it and the solver measures
anyway
a lot of data which is underutilized yet
with all of that
look-aheads and so on there's a lot of
data uh which i believe um
and i'm working on that we could to
make much more progress with that and
then definitely so this interleaving of
these different techniques so kind of
the look ahead perhaps more at the
planet
as marine perhaps said the look ahead
has more the planning oversight is less
good possibly with
solving the problem but it has a better
statistical overview and this kind of
combination especially also
said so so that in the future i believe
that there's a good chance
because the look ahead heuristics we
understand somewhat better
i i think quite a bit better than the
cdcl heuristics
uh i'm going to use dynamic heuristic
here
houston has just been hit by by
thunderstorm
and i'm concerned a little bit about
loss of power
so i'm going to ask g where to go next
rather than jacob as originally planned
and number two if i disappear
or if you wait if if i disappear i'll
ask albert to replace me as chair
and let's go with ga before we lose
power here
so thank you maran yeah please stop
sharing please stop sharing
stop sharing yeah and we will i will
comment on the under the the questions
uh by email or yeah
and let's go with here next i'm sorry
jacob i'm just
we had a little experience with loss of
power so we are less stressful to
now of the of the power system
guys here yes go ahead there's you
thank you moshe for the introduction
hello everyone my name is joey john
and it's really my great pleasure to
speak here at simon's
institute today i'm going to tell you
about our work on a continuous local
research approach for hybrid
solving and this is a joint work with
anatosis qualities
and summary survival and
so when we are talking about step
solving what are we
really referring to and as in most cases
we mean seeing f solving of course c
f is the most prevalent and successful
format in set community
but there are also other very important
and useful nonsense boolean constraints
which are much less studied in this
community
in graph theory there are a lot of
examples
for instance for vertex covering it's
more convenient to
represent this problem by either
cardinality constraints or
pseudo boolean constraints another
example is
the hyper graph 2 coloring where not all
equal constraints
is the most natural representation
while in cryptography xlr constraints
play
important rules for composing protocols
like sha-1
and i'm sure that you can list other
applications to
demonstrate the importance of nonsense
boolean constraints
so what have people done for handling
nonsense of constraints
there are two main lines of research the
first one is encoding
in tokens have been discussed in
previous workshops
but here i want to make the list some
limitations of
encodings first is about size
so here is the uh histogram about
the blow up of number of variables and
clauses if we just want to
encode a cardinality constraint with 250
variables
so you can see the blow up here and it
is no doubt bringing
a heavy burden to the solar and the
slowdown down
beside the size encodings can vary a lot
by other aspects like arc consistency
and the solution density
so uh usually different solvers prefer
different encodings
and the takeaway message here is that
just because
including is found for type of
constraint doesn't mean
it is solver friendly
well the second aspect for handling
non-cf constraint is to use
extensions of cdcl based set servers
there are a bunch of tools developed
in this area but we want to make the
point here that
they need to design algorithms for each
specific type of constraints
while a uniform way for handling
different types of constraint is still
lagging
so both of those lines of research kind
of rely
on cdcl servers
with city cell servers relies highly on
the property
of seeing that format so we are thinking
about
can we use a more general approach
namely local search
so local search engine research usually
the objective function is defined
by the number of constraints of formula
satisfied
by some assignments there are many many
classical rhythms in this area gsat is
one of them
where you start from a random initial
point and
you just keep flipping the variables
with the best value
until you reach a solution
local search gives us interesting
theoretical results and in practice
it was shown to be effective on rent
hard random and private instances as
well as med side instances
so we want to ask can we use discrete
research
for announcing of solving
let's see what happens so remember that
discrete research
also relies on some properties of cnaf
which is
an unsatisfied clause can always be
fixed by flipping just
one variable but
does this probably also hold if we want
to solve non's enough constraints
and probably not let's see the following
example
here we have a cardinality constraint
with four variables and
suppose we start from this all false
assignment
now it is unsatisfied and we will try to
flip
one variable let's say the first one to
make this
new x now there are two things to note
notice the first one is that the
constraint is still on set
the second thing is that and the even
worst thing is that if we just
use the way we define the discrete
objective function
in c f solving we will see no
change to the discrete objective
although we think that we are making
some progress because we are closer to
satisfying this cognitive constraint
so that indicates some problems with
using discrete objectives for nonsense
solving
the first one is that discrete local
search is limited to flip a single bit
pre-iteration
second discrete objective function fails
to capture
the progress towards satisfying a
nonsense
constraint so maybe stay
in discrete domain is not enough
and here is what we are planning to
solve those problems
for as for discrete objective fails to
capture progress
we we plan to design a continuous
fitness function
to measure the progress since district
load search is limited to flip a single
bit per iteration
we are thinking of just search inside of
the box
and do continuous research so that we
are kind of flipping
more than one bit simultaneously maybe
we'll just flip each bit slightly
but we can manipulate a subset of bits
instead of just one
so i think it's a good point to wrap up
a little bit and
show you some really work on continuous
approaches for stat solving
which is not a new thing because people
have uh
developed both convex realizations and
non-combat polynomial
representations for step solving
so for the left part we do have lp
relaxation and
as the periodicization those
realizations gives
us good theoretical guarantees but they
usually fail to give high quality
solutions in practice
while on the right the client formula is
usually
transformed into a sum of product
polynomial
but in the previous literature they
failed to give
sufficient theoretical analysis about
this transformation
and also note that this transform only
applies on cnn format while we want to
solve
nonsense constraints as well
one point that's both of those
directions are missing
is the success of gradient-based
techniques
achieved in machine learning and we
believe that those
advantages and new techniques are not
fully leveraged
in the stat community so we want to
explore
the potential of continuous local search
so here i will just show you the overall
workflow of our
framework and the goal is to
design an effective framework that
handles different types of constraints
uniformly we are giving
so our input is hybrid boolean formula
and we can do some kind of transform
which i will describe later
to generate a multilinear polynomial
then we will be able to do continuous
optimization based on some gradient
approaches we may end up converting to
global maximum local maximum or seven
point
but no matter which point we convert to
we can always discriticize it
to check if it is a solution or not if
not we just go back and
do random restart
so in the rest of this talk i will be
decomposing this framework
into different pieces and show you how
each component actually works
the first and the most important part of
our framework
is how we define this continuous fitness
function
let's go for it remember that the
discrete objective function is just the
number of constraints
the number of satisfied constraints
as we discussed before this function is
kind of
too discrete so that it fails to capture
some small progress
towards satisfying nonsense constraints
so can we define a real value fitness
function for the boolean formula
usually the one of the ways people do it
is to define
a real value function by probability
space here is how we do it
we want to define a fitness real value
function
for all the real vector which are
constrained in the
boolean box from minus one to one
so we can define a probability space
based on the real vector a
the probability space will be applied on
all the boolean
vectors
so here is how we do it they these
coordinates
of the boolean vector will be
independent from each other
and the value of x i will be only
decided
will be only related with the value of a
i
so roughly speaking if a i is positive
then x
i has a greater chance of being 1 if
sampled from the probability of space sa
and if ai is negative
then vice versa here is an example
a is a 2d real vector
and here is a table probability table
showing
how what's the probability of each
variable taking some specific value
and we can sample a boolean vector from
this table
so after we get this probability of
space one of the
uh way that we can define our real
vector
real value function is to use a
probability
that the formula is true under this
probability space
right so this looks good
but unfortunately this probability is
sharp pre-complete to evaluate
because it just it reduces to the
model counting problem
but we can step back and compute
something easier
which is the expectation of the original
objective function under this
probability space
so what happens if we choose this
representation
now the capital f the fitness function
measures how many constraints are
satisfied
in expectation under the probability
space
and we can next try to maximize this
fitness function with respect to a which
is constrained
in the boolean box where a is a real
vector
so generally speaking this real
value fitness function gives us a way to
to measure how good
a real vector is while we're doing a
search
the next next question to ask is how to
evaluate
this fitness function a naive approach
takes at
exponential time of course but it turns
out
that this fitness function can be
evaluated in polynomial time
by the so-called watchfoil expansions
which i will describe in the next
slide the watchful expansion is the main
theoretical technique we are using in
our framework
while ryan has written a remarkable
textbook
on this topic i will just give a brief
introduction
it is basically a technique which
transforms boolean functions to
multilinear polynomials for example
the formula if the formula is x and y
then i will claim that this polynomial
is the first expansion the reason is if
you
evaluate this polynomial on all the four
possible
discrete assignments you will see that
the boolean function and the polynomial
agree with each other and this
phenomenon is general
in the sense that every single boolean
constraint has a unique representation a
multi-linear polynomial
that agree with the constraint on all
the boolean assignments
but what happens on the real vectors
the polynomial itself does not prevent
us from evaluating it on real vectors
if we do so we may generate a surface in
high dimensional space with it which is
useful
in our framework so how does
it help us to evaluate our objective
function
recall that we define our real domain
fitness function by the expectation
so by the linearity of expectation we
can expand
this representation to the sum of
probability
that each constraint is true under the
space that we defined by a the real
vector
one of the contribution we made is that
this probability can be computed exactly
by evaluating the fourier expression if
we just
use the same real vector a on both sides
of the equation
so now we are able to rewrite our
fitness function by the sum of fourier
expansions
of each constraint here is
an example now phi has two different
constraints and we can transform them
both into
their corresponding fourier polynomials
and add them up to get our polynomial
representation
of fitness function so we will be able
to evaluate
it so here finish
our first part and the second part is
about
versatility so since we are motivated by
handling non-cf constraints and so we
will see how we do it
recall that our fitness function is
defined
can be rewritten as the sum of four
expansions so if we have a new type of
constraint and
we know they can close form for your
expansions of that constraint then we'll
do it
but for what type of constraint can we
do it
fortunately many types of interesting
constraints
have their closed form for expansions
from add sort to
cardinality constraints to not oracle
constraints and they
including seeing nothing cnf clauses
further proved that for all symmetric
constraints we have their own
their closed form for expansions
so here comes to the last part and i
believe that
in this part a lot of questions can be
raised for example
can we say anything about global maximum
center points or local maximum
or how fast is the convergence or after
with this
criticize the converting points what
is the quality of this assignment
so let's answer these questions
regarding convergence and rounding
the first thing i want to tell you here
is about
global and local maxima
another contribution we made is to prove
global maxima or all preserved in real
box
if we what do i mean by that let's first
consider the scenario in
discrete load research in this regular
search
phi is satisfiable if and only if the
maximum
of the discrete objective value is that
is the number of constraints
this is easy to see and what we have
proven
is that this theorem also holds
in the continuous space so here i need
to replace
the discrete objective value to the our
fitness function
which is real value and
i need now the maximum operator is
applied on all the possible
real vectors in the box constraint
and the maximum of the fitness function
is still
the number of constraints so that means
the fitness function is well behaved
inside of the tube and it won't exist
it exits the number of constraints
we cannot end up finding some global
maximum inside of the tube
so it's not always realistic to convert
to a global maximum
so we have to consider the case where we
go to a local maxima
can we say anything about local maxima
to answer this question we need to study
the geometry of multi-linear polynomials
so multi-linear polynomials are globally
non-convex and non-concave which is not
useful for optimization but locally
multilinear polynomials are always
convex along some directions while
concave on some other directions
so as a result neither of this ball
shaped local minimum
nor this local maximum can appear
on the surface of multilinear
polynomials
the only place which may trap our search
is
such a saddle shape
but sample shape is not the worst thing
in search because
we have a great chance of escaping from
it
uh formally speaking if we do not
apply our bots constraints on every
point there will always be a direction
where we can increase the value
in the polynomial value but if if we
uh impose our bot's constraint then this
escaping direction may be towards the
boundary so we must still encounter
local maxima along the boundary or in
other words
the local maxima should be on the
boundary
so this kind of reveals of the
discrete nature of our framework despite
of
its continuous appearance
so we formalized our intuition by
proving that
all look maxima are almost discrete
assignments
so what do i mean by almost discrete
let's see an example
now phi is x or y logically speaking if
one of x
or y takes value 2 then no matter what
value the other variable takes
phi should always be true this also
holds in the
polynomial world so now f
is the corresponding polynomial and we
can see
on the plot that on the blue point at
the blue point we can
we can move the blue points along the
axis without changing the polynomial
value
so that means we can round the
fractional coordinates
which does not matter at some specific
point
so those points are so called almost
discrete
because if we just reach this point i
think we should stop
search and maybe do random restart
because
cert continue searching is not useful at
all
what we proved is that you can start
from a fractional point
at the beginning but if you are able to
convert to a local maximum
then uh you will finally end up with the
following point
where most of the coordinates are
discrete which means they are either
plus one or minus one
while this a small set of variables are
fractional
but we don't care about those variables
because changing
the values of those variables does not
affect the value of the fitness function
in other words for a local maximum
rounding preserves
the objective value
so this somehow gives us some guarantees
about the solution quality of local
maxima
because randy now does not harm which is
different from the case
in lp both lp and the sdp relaxation
where running pn cost loss
to the objective
in other words local maxima are
meaningful and they do
provide good quality solutions for some
more relaxed
problems like mad set
i also want to answer the question about
how fast can we converge
first of all i want to emphasize that
our framework does not limit anything
about
which optimizer you should use so you
can use any optimizer as long as
as long as it solves the constraint
of polynomial optimization problem but
here we will focus on the
projective gradient and sense approach
for those who are not familiar with it
it is just general gradient ascent
but projecting the outlier back to the
box region by finding the nearest point
so sometimes when it happens the
projected gradient
will be different than the ordinal
gradient
a point is called a critical point if
the projected gradient
at that point is absolute small and our
one of our theorem is that if
if our framework uses projected gradient
descent
then it will always converge to a
critical point
in polynomial steps
but what does a critical point
look like in most real-life cases
quicker points are just
local maxima which will prove that
they have good quality but theoretically
speaking
a critical point can still be a saddle
point so you can see a gap here
on one hand we prove that local maxima
are
meaningful but on the other hand we can
only
prove that we will convert to a critical
point
the reason this step exists is because
of set of points
several points it's other point is a
critical point that is not
a local optima like this one
although in real life cases center point
will exist
really exists but in
some crafted instances they can appear
for example those are the gradient plots
for
outsourced constraints you can see that
just at the middle of the boolean box
saddle point
exists where the gradient vanishes
but practically we observed that
our framework seldom converts to such
style points
so an open question we raise here is to
prove that our framework does not
convert to
this other point with high probability
so here here i think the framework has
been
introduced so in this slide i want to
tell you some improvements that we made
on this framework
in our newest paper where we use a new
representation of boolean constraints
called binary decision diagram
we use bdd to handle coefficient bounded
pseudo boolean constraints
since the efficiency of computing the
gradient
is very important for
continuous local search we accelerated
the gradient communication by bdd
significantly also we do
we are aware of the fact that inside
community
converging to a global maximum is much
more important than just having a
local maximum so we also use adaptive
constraint weighting borrowed from
discrete
research to get better global
convergence
so if you are interested in any topics
of this
i encourage you to refer to our newest
paper
so it's time to show you some
experimental results
the highlight of our framework is its
performance on
some small size playing matsub
computation
where our approach gives the best
solution for most cases
compared with other match set
servers well we also tested our two
um some real hybrid boolean formulas
containing xor and the pseudo boolean
constraints
um well we observed that our server is
better than discrete load research
servers but
it cannot match the performance of
state-of-the-art cd sales server or sudo
boolean
servers yet of course the city of the
art stores are well engineered
and usually the continuous operation is
much more expensive than
the it's discrete counterpart
so we believe that those results already
show some
uh great potential of this framework
uh on large industrial instances the
cost for differentiation
is really too expensive so we need to
work on that
all right in summary we are motivated by
handling constraints that beyond cnf
and we want to explore the potential of
continuous methods
in saturn method solving our framework
exhibits nice theoretical results as
well as
interesting open questions as a
continuous based approach
in practice our server can
act as a complement to existing servers
since the framework can be decomposed
into parts
it should be bent it should benefit from
the
improvement from each area for example
tractable structures of boolean
constraints and the techniques in
continuous optimization
as for challenges and the future
directions
first of all the full gradient is really
expensive on industrial benchmarks so we
want to compute imprecise gradients
second we also want to learn from
discrete
search to combine that with our
framework
to design a server with better
performance
third since the neural symbolic approach
is really
popular now our solver exhibits good
potential of being as a layer of
neural network as a differential
optimizer
also we want to verify the real value
fitness function
to see if we can find any insights of
different
logical formulas we also want to connect
our algorithm with some welding matrix
message passing algorithms
like survey propagation and we will dig
more into this with that i would like to
conclude my talk
thanks for listening and i'm happy to
take questions
thank you g way for a very nice talk uh
looks like jacob has a question i think
yes please
uh you mean in speak out so
yes do i get it right that this is an
incomplete method
that is yes it is so
complete yeah and did so did you
considering like combining it with
some complete method that could do like
the unsatisfiability part and maybe you
would do the search part
or this is on the list of things new or
it doesn't work or
[Music]
yeah so if you mean by proving
unsatisfied built it by other
completely different methods yes of
course we can do that but if you mean
prove proving unsatisfiability by
algebraic approach
like groups and basis or
like other approaches then we we think
people have done that before but they
failed to scale well
so we haven't done that yet
but there is jacob there is interesting
insight for example how you look at
resolution from this algebraic
perspective so it turns out the
resolution here translates to
to linear operations
right uh yes exactly
so there is a potential to do to add for
example kind of inferencing
yes so there is a potential but it's
hard to see how they can be as efficient
as resolution
currently
other questions or comments
yeah i would have a question so like uh
would it not also make sense to have an
imprecise encoding into bdd so similar
like what the
hooker and other colleagues from cmu are
doing for optimization like
dropping those sort of high degree
monomials you have in your four year
because you're only staying here on this
conclusion slight uh sort of imprecise
gradient but you could also do an
imprecise
uh imprint size encoding exactly so
i think um using an
any exact representation of the
polynomials corresponds to
cut off some nodes of the corresponding
bdd
so they are basically the same it's just
a spectrum
method with keeping the compo the the
major component
okay um i have
asked a quick question yes only then um
so in the first part you
for the basis uh depending so you define
that expected
expectation depending on the variable a
and then the second part as i understand
it
you optimize over that a now that
expectation
looked uh have not did not fully grasp
it but it looked
natural to me um but um um
[Music]
are there alternatives to that or do you
think that's it
so that's the natural choice to to that
basic definition from the first part
well so so our the question is a
question about
whether we can do better than defining a
fitness function based on expectation
can we use alternative
definitions yes yes so
do you have any comments margin no maybe
even change the probability distribution
yes yes those are all promising
directions but
we did tried several different
representations
but the expectation is the most suitable
one because it is multi-linear
which means it is somehow smooth
and uh yeah so it's a balance between
easy computable is it computable and uh
and
precise
so last question i'll read the questions
from the from embry
which is the deal we consider to doing
parallel cells starting from multiple
points
and then using perhaps the power of gpus
yes that is definitely a promising
direction because our
very much exhibits a good potential of
that
so yeah i believe that
the the performance of our of our
framework depends on
how many trials you have you're doing
and if we can manage to
parallelize it on gpus
it would be very nice but since the
search contains some
some logical steps it's not clear how to
do it
at this moment
okay well thank you thank you guy for
the presentation thanks thanks for all
the questions and
thank jacob for his patience and now we
are going to switch to jacob
and the storm has subsided so i'm
optimistic that we'll be able to finish
it
[Music]
jacob would you like to share your
slides i'm doing my best
let's see do they show up now yep
[Music]
okay okay
yes okay so
right thanks for for uh
staying for the final talk uh so i'm
jakob nordstrom
the university of copenhagen london
university and i'm going to talk about
pseudo boolean solving as something
sitting right in between set solving and
integer linear programming
so so what is pseudo boolean solving
maybe the first question
you know apart from being a cool name
well as a theoretician
i would call this is just a function
over the boolean hypercube
um and um they have they're well studied
in operations research in inter-linear
programming
so we are going to be interested in um
when these pseudo-boolean functions are
linear functions
and that is enough to express a lot of
if you think of your
favorite np-complete problems then
chances are actually that it can be
expressed in linear pseudo-boolean form
and i should say right away that
what you'll get now is like a condensed
version of
um mostly a condensed version of what i
did during the summer's boot camp
so um you can view this as a teaser for
going to
that tutorial and listening to more of
the details there
but i'll uh i'll add some new twists i
guess especially towards the end
just to convince you that you should
stay um
anyway so why why do we want to do sudo
boolean
constraints so one reason is that it's a
much richer format than the cnf
format that sat solvers use i mean just
to say
out of six variables you want to say
that three are true that's just
one cardinality constraint uh as
you know opposed to this mouthful of
clauses where it's even hard to see that
i didn't do a
you know a bug somewhere i think in
earlier versions of these slides i even
had bugs
and i didn't even see them and in
addition once you move over to
pseudo-boolean constraints it turns out
that
you actually have stronger methods of
reasoning than the resolution method
that underlies cdcl
um and but but the bonus is that you're
still close enough to set to look at all
the cool ideas that have
uh appeared in set solving and you could
try to port them
to the pseudo boolean setting plus since
you
have a zero one interior linear program
and there are lots of interesting ideas
in in the mixed integer linear
programming community you can try to
to take ideas from there as well
okay so so just to make clear we're on
the same page
so suitable and constraints then will be
linear constraints
uh for the rest of this talk where uh i
have integer coefficients
an integer constant term uh literals
that's just variables or negative
variables
um that take values true or false um
so one or zero um and and in general
like in a suitable constraint you could
have any way of comparing them but we
will
focus on it won't be too important for
the talk but it's like
kind of nice when you describe the how
you reason with sudo boolean constraints
and when you implement algorithms to use
what's called normalized form
where all of these coefficients and the
constant term they're non-negative
integers
and the reason that you can do this
without loss of generality is that if
you have a negative coefficient
for x i you just switch to not x i
instead
and in this normalized setting
the the constant term is is known as the
degree
or the degree of falsity okay
so just to make sure again continue
our discussion to make sure we're on the
same page so
if you have a clauses in cnf those are
just special cases of pseudo-boolean
constraints because you just sum up the
literals and want at least one of them
to be true
and then we saw that cardinality
constraints is an example of a more
general class of constraints
and then you can go wild and have
arbitrary
coefficients like this constraint
which is like a general pseudo boolean
constraint and another thing that is
nice with pseudo-boolean constraints is
that you can express a lot of things
staying inside this formalism for
instance sometimes it's useful to have
a variable encode the truth value of a
constraint say that i want z
to be true precisely when this
constraint holds
so the nice thing is that this also i
can write as a pair
of pseudo boolean constraints and i
won't go too much into the details but
you can see that
just the first line is the easiest one
to see here that
this says that if z is true this forces
indeed forces this constraint to be true
and then if you look at the second line
and you think a bit more then you
realize that
uh z false will actually force this
constraint to be false
so pseudo-boolean constraints are
expressive
and nice to work with and what
so the input that we have are then
pseudo-boolean formulas just
conjunctions of such constraints
and then we have two problems that i
want to discuss with you
and one is just the satisfiability
problem but ported to sudo boolean
to sudo boolean settings so this is
pseudo boolean solving you
get a collection of pseudo
pseudo-boolean constraints
and you want to know whether they are
satisfiable or whether they're feasible
but another bonus with
going to pseudo boolean form is that
you can have you can express
optimization problems in a in a nice and
natural way
so you can also have some linear
combination of literals weighted by some
coefficients wi
and that you want to minimize say
without loss of generality
so then the problem becomes that you
want to find
a satisfying assignment to f and among
all such assignments you want to
minimize
the objective so that's that's the
the setting that's the problem that we
want to understand and
um so what i'm going to tell you a
little bit about
is how you can do this by using
so-called pseudo-boolean solvers
and i'll then also
try to discuss how you can borrow ideas
from the sat side in particular from max
sat solving and also from mixed integer
linear programming
and this is again going to be like more
of a
a brief overview talk or a sales pitch
that i think this is something that
might be interesting to look more into
and so i'll
try to give you some pointers and there
are some um
some literature references on the slides
and they are all available at the end of
the slides which i
assume might be somewhere on the simon's
webpage later or if not then they will
be on my web pages
okay so what do you do if you get a
pseudo-boolean formula
well one thing that you can do since you
know and love conflict driven close
running solvers you just rewrite your
sudo boolean constraints
to conjunctive normal form and run your
favorite set solver
this is one thing you can do
another approach which is the one that
i've been working more on is
so in one sense you're like you want to
stay with conflict driven
close learning but you port your input
from sudo boolean to cnf so i want to go
in the other direction mostly i want to
stay with the pseudo boolean format and
i want to port
cdcl to a sudo boolean setting
and in particular i think there are two
solvers that are being actively
developed that i know of that are
following this approach and this is set
for jay by the team in in lance
france and then rounding set which is
being developed by our group
um so okay how do you do it
what how does cdcl-based suitable
insolving work
well it it's it's being used because it
turns out that it's uh
often a very competitive approach and
you know sadly i have to say from the
point of view of so-called native celu
boolean solving
the cdcl based approaches sometimes just
beat the crap out of us
and it's interesting to understand why
and i don't fully
understand why so that's an interesting
research question but
you can i mean it can be noted that when
you
rewrite the pseudoboolean formula to
cnf then you're introducing extension
variables
and these extension variables they mean
interesting things
and they so they give you a lot of extra
power
um and that means that if you have a
disjunction over such
extension variables then actually that
encodes some kind of polytope if you
look at the original problem so it
in some sense that we don't really
understand it it gives you a way of
doing fairly powerful reasoning just
because the variables
mean things that um you couldn't speak
about before in a pseudo-boolean solver
because there was no variable for this
thing however
in order for this to work you really
want your uh formula to be encoded in a
nice way so for instance if i'm evil
and i try to permute the variables and
the constraints so that they come in a
not so natural order
then it seems that the cdcl based
approaches take a huge hit in
performance
and also um for some problems like say
you're if you're working on on pigeon
principle formulas
you just have the basic fact that no
encoding into
cnf can compensate for the fact that
cdcl-based reasoning
is exponentially weaker than uh
pseudo-boolean reasoning for such
formulas and this you can also see
sometimes um
so uh but but there are like i think a
lot of
uh interesting problems so like one
interesting problem is
uh when you're doing the rewriting how
do you
rewrite to cnf in the best possible way
um
there is a lot of research on this a lot
of different
encodings um i don't think we really
understand
from a rigorous point of view which
encodings are good or bad
another interesting question is how
would you
i'd like to understand better how the cd
seal-based approaches
uh compared to the cutting beans cutting
planes based approaches that i'm going
to
discuss briefly next in particular they
seem to be somewhat complementary and it
would be
nice to well on the one hand to
theoretically understand what's going on
for instance could we somehow pin down
how helpful these new auxiliary
variables are this i
don't understand and also i mean if
if the cdcl-based approach is sometimes
good and the
cutting planes based approach is
sometimes good then why don't we try to
build a solver
that somehow tries to do both and get
the best of both worlds
i think this would be a nice thing to do
[Music]
okay so um so moving on to
pseudo-boolean conflict-driven search so
this is now when i want to keep
my input in sudo boolean form
but i want to
do like the conflict-driven search and
learning because i've seen how good that
is
in set solving so like do the same thing
as as in cdcl but using
cutting planes instead of the resolution
proof system
and operating on pseudo-boolean
constraints rather than
clauses so what do i mean by the same
thing
well we would have the same setup where
there is this cycle of
assigning deciding on variables and then
making obvious propagations so you have
a decision propagation cycle
and there's a natural way of
generalizing
what it means for a pseudo boolean
constraint to propagate
and right if if for suitable and
constraints will be violated
unless i set x to true then that means
that this pseudo boolean constraint
x to true so i do this
decision propagation cycle until i hit
the conflict which is a violated
constraint
and then what i want to do is i want to
look at all on my
all of my propagations that i've made
that led to this conflict i want to look
at these constraints
and then i want to do conflict analysis
and learn a new constraint
but this constraint is going to be sudo
boolean
and i'm going to have to use some other
form of reasoning
than a resolution to do it and
the reasoning that we're going to use uh
is
cutting planes so cutting planes like
traditional cutting planes is this
so that we know that all literals are
non-negative
and then we know that we can take
positive linear combinations so c
a and c b are positive numbers here
and then you have this division rule
which just says that
and here i'm using that the constraint
is written in normalized form that all
of these coefficients
are positive then i can just divide by a
c and round up everywhere
so this is like how cutting planes is is
presented in the
proof complexity literature going back
to cook at all
but then if you're doing solving you
also want to use the saturation rule and
maybe
saturation is easier to see by an
example also division by an example so
suppose
suppose i have this constraint x plus 2y
plus 4z
greater than or equal to 3. then if i
divide by 2
and round up everywhere then i get x
plus y
plus 2z greater or equal to so this is
what division does
what saturation does it says well i mean
if this constraint is satisfied then
having the coefficient four here is
clearly overdoing it
actually three is enough so if this
constraint x plus two y plus four z
greater
greater equal three holds then the same
constraint with three z instead
also holds both of these rules
importantly
are using that we know uh that the
variables
are are integers so this is like
the rest of the rules this is just uh
linear programming basically but here
you have the boolean rules
and it's nice to have boolean rules if
we're going to solve boolean problems
so but doing the same thing just
but just with pseudo-boolean constraint
that's opening a can of worms and i
think this is like
an area where we could really use more
uh
uh research um one the first annoying
problem is that if you take this fancy
pseudo-boolean solver
but you feed it a cnf formula in the
proper pseudo boolean encoding
then everything just collapses to cdcl
but with very very expensive data
structures and this is a major weakness
as i see it
something that has been proposed is to
try to rewrite
your input and see if it could be
rewritten to for instance cardinality
constraints in a better way
and this has been implemented but it's
not actually
yet good enough to be used in practice
um so so you really so one thing if you
if you're going to use a pseudo boolean
solver you have to pay attention to your
encoding
like don't use the cnf encoding if your
problem is really a cnf problem
then you probably shouldn't be using a
sudo boolean solver
another problem is that even if you get
a nice encoding
we do have examples of where
you have zero one integer linear
programs where even the linear
relaxation
is infeasible so you don't need any
boolean reasoning to decide that there
is no solution i mean just just
just linear programming is enough and
this should be very easy for cutting
planes reasoning and still
solvers take forever this is another
very annoying
fact a third area of possible
improvement
is that pre-processing is something that
is very important in set solving it's
also
being used in inter linear programming
but so far
the pseudo-boolean solvers don't really
have it
and this is probably another source of
of possible improvement
um so these are like i guess saying that
there i believe there is quite a
bit of low hanging fruit where you can
take
insights from either set solving or
interlinear programming and if you just
implement it then probably pseudo
boolean solvers would become much better
[Music]
another interesting uh question is that
it turns out that when you're doing this
conflict analysis on pseudo-boolean
constraints then
many degrees of freedom arise and again
going into details would be
take a lot of time so i have to refer
you to the tutorial but there are a lot
of like
scenarios that a lot of choices that you
just didn't have before
in cdcl but with suitable and
constraints you do for instance
um i mean in in cdcl you're going to do
your conflict analysis with
resolution period but in a
pseudo-boolean setting you could use
maybe division maybe saturation maybe
combining them maybe doing something
else
you can massage your pseudo-boolean
constraints and simplify them in
different ways
when you finally decide to learn a
constraint it can be
asserting at several different levels so
how far should you back jump
another thing is since the coefficients
are integers
what kind of precision do you want do
you want to stay in fixed position
and round when you're overflowing or do
you want to be in arbitrary position
um and just as such a basic question of
of what is a good learned constraint
what is a strong constraint
for a clause this is in some sense
obvious
the fewer literals you have in a clause
the stronger it is
but for a pseudo boolean constraint
there it's like at least two dimensional
on the one hand you have how many
variables it involves but
the question is also how the
coefficients relate
to the degree of falsity and so you
could be in a scenario where you can
learn
several incomparable constraints and we
don't have a good sense of which one is
the best one
and they're also interesting theoretical
questions about understanding
different subsystem of cutting planes
for instance how does
cunning planes with division compare to
the canning planes using saturation
lots of room for for improving our
understanding there
uh but still i mean this these
solvers do work well uh in the sense
that there are a lot of
uh if you have a decision problem and if
it's natural
to encode in pseudo-boolean form
then we do have lots of examples where
pseudo-boolean solvers are clearly
stronger than cdcl solvers
not not just pigeon or principle
formulas would be like the the obvious
toy example but also lots of other
examples going
further from decision problems to
optimization problems
we can borrow ideas from max
sat so one obvious way to do
optimization is just linear search
so you run your solver and you want to
minimize this objective function say
sum of of w-i-l-i for later sli
just run the solver find a solution and
then you add a constraint saying now i
want something better i want something
smaller than what you found
and run the solver again and keep going
until
the formula is unsatisfiable at which
point
you know you found an optimal solution
this
is like simple but it works reasonably
well in particular
you can often get a decent solution
quickly which might be interesting
in applied scenarios where you actually
not interested in solving to optimality
but maybe you have limited time and you
want some decent solution
quickly and linear search can be good
but of course the downside is that you
don't
know how good your solution is because
you have no idea of of what the matching
lower bound might be
another interesting idea also from
uh maxat is like
the duel is to do core guided search so
now you say okay
here's my objective let's be optimistic
the best possible scenario here would be
that it's possible to set all literals
to zero
that we give the minimum zero i'm
assuming again here that all the wi's
are non-negative so i'll just assume
this i'll run my solver with assumptions
so pre-made decisions
for setting the whole objective function
to zero and now
one of two things can happen either this
works out and then i've clearly found
the
optimal solution or it doesn't and then
i learn
the reason why that you know maybe some
collection
of of these literals at least a of them
have to be true
okay and then i can use this
to update my estimate of what the pos
best possible solution is and
i can actually also rewrite the
objective function by introducing new
variables
and run from the top again and
keep going until i find an optimal
solution which will be when my
when in my rewritten objective function
i can set everything to zero
uh then i know i have the optimal value
and then i have sort of computed
uh how much i changed my objective
during this rewriting
so this means that i work with lower
bounds and it can
turns out that it can be helpful to get
good lower bounds because this help
cuts this helps to cut off the search
space you know
it cuts off places where there's no
reason to go
the downside is obviously that you don't
find a solution until
you have the optimal solution and you
don't know for that reason you don't
know how good your lower bound is
uh so then you know what if we try to
combine linear search
and um core guided search wouldn't that
be nice and it turns out that yes it
would be
and the nice thing compared to maxsite
is that this is much much cleaner and
simpler to do
in a pseudo boolean setting so this is
something that we did
um and i had in in triple ai just a
few weeks ago um
so here for comparison here are our two
good um pseudo boolean solvers sat4j
and then the cdcl based solver naps and
here are different versions
different combinations of pseudo boolean
solving with core guided search
and linear search interleaved and
if you compare like these rows and the
rules down here you can see that there
are overall like significant
improvements sadly however we're not
beating the academic mip solver skip
i'll get back to that
in a in a minute
um so
what's up with with uh map solvers
so map solvers actually solve a much
more general
problem so then you have
some of the variables will be integral
and not necessarily boolean and other
variables will be real valued
except as as a special case if you don't
have any real valued variables then you
have an integer linear program and
in an if in addition all of these
variables are bounded between zero and
one
then you have a zero one integer linear
program which is just another name for
the
for the pseudo boolean formulas that we
started with um
and if you want to do pseudo boolean
solving then you just do
you give a vacuous objective function
but it turns out that mip solvers are
not so good for decision problems they
somehow
they really use the objective function
heavily
to guide the search so we we we're
actually have it's not so hard to find
um decision problems where
pseudo-boolean solders will beat
mip solvers but finding optimization
problems
where sudo boolean solvers are better
that is not so easy
so what mips always do is again they
have
as i already said they have
pre-processing which is important
and then they work by
not trying to find boolean solutions but
instead they relax
the problem solve linear programming
linear programming relaxations and then
try to
use that to
store information about how good or bad
the solution can be and then they use
something that's called branch and bound
and they also derive new
integer linear inequalities that rule
out
uh solutions to the relaxation that are
not integral
and this is something that's called
branch and cut
and then you combine this with lots and
lots of heuristics
okay so if you compare to pseudo boolean
solvers
um pseudo boolean solvers have really
good conflict analysis
um but as i already mentioned they
are not great even on some problems
where the lp relaxation is infeasible
they
still run forever this is a scenario
where mip solars would terminate
immediately because they solve
just in the very first root node they
solve the lp relaxation they see that
it's infeasible they terminate
immediately
okay so mixed integer linear programming
solvers have
powerful search they use the lp
relaxations they have lots of different
ways of adding constraints
but when you show infeasibility then
they basically just backtrack
so this suggests that why don't we try
to get the best of both worlds we
use the powerful search of mip and then
the sophisticated conflict analysis of
pseudo-boolean solvers
okay this sounds great it's easier said
than done
but we have done this
so what we did we took our solar
rounding sat and
integrated it with the lp solver
suplex from this mip solver skip
and then you can add different belts and
whistles you can also take these
gomorrah cuts that are computed to rule
out lp relaxation solutions you can also
ask the pseudo-boolean solver to share
the constraints that it learns during
conflict analysis to send them to the lp
solver
and when we run this on knapsack
problems then we see that all of these
techniques
so here is like the base rounding sat
and all of these techniques
really make the solver significantly
better although we're still not beating
skip but
in fairness it should be said also that
mip solvers have a lot of special
purpose methods
to detect and solve knapsack constraints
with for instance dynamic programming
and we don't do that we're just running
our standard conflict driven search here
um let's compare to some other
benchmarks so
if we look at the pseudo boolean
competition benchmarks decision and
optimization instances and some
miplib instances again decision and
optimization
problems then um well i guess we don't
get the
performance that we were hoping for uh
but at least the hybrid solver is always
second best so like if you had to pick
one solver then you shouldn't pick the
pseudo boolean solver you shouldn't pick
the mixed
mips or you should pick our hybrid
because it's always like you know
reasonably good although it would have
been nicer if it i mean clearly
you could also make the argument that if
you care about optimization then still
it seems like mip solvers are winning
um so but
this is i think it's it's it's um
before we conclude from this that that
sudo boolean solvers
are hopeless it should be noted that
there's been like tons and tons of
manures in
invested in uh coding up
fine tuning mib solvers there are huge
industrial solvers
and and uh pseudo boolean solving is
really
in comparison not at all that well
explored so i would argue that
the fact that you can get this good
results with so limited effort
to me this shows that i think sudo
boolean soros is something we should
look more deeply into and there are lots
of of interesting
problems one could look at how to
interact between the
the linear programming solver and the pb
solver
how to make the pseudo boolean solver
use information from the lp relaxations
for instance that we don't do
um i already mentioned that why don't we
use pre-processing
in particular we could take the mip
pre-solving techniques that work in a
pseudo boolean setting and
tag them on so this is you have to be a
little bit careful because some
mips solving techniques will change zero
one integer linear programming
problems into other types of problems
but it should be possible to deal with
this
another interesting fact is that that
you have a wide like a rich library of
different cut rules that you could in
principle plug into suitable and
conflict analysis and see
if something better pops out this is
something that i really would like to do
and now this is like ends where i was in
my tutorial and after the tutorial
during the boot camp i basically got
questions saying that nice but you know
why would any sane person actually do
sudo boolean solving
so then i realized that i was maybe
underselling a little bit
so i want you know for fairness sake i
want to balance the picture and say that
there are in fact
applications where already pseudo
boolean solvers are outperforming even
commercial mip solvers you just take
you know a standard sudo boolean solver
off the shelf and for instance for
problems like arithmetic circuit
verification it turns out that
pseudo boolean solvers are state of the
art
some people in glasgow
matching doing some kind of matching
problems for children with adoptive
families apparently
they take the same problems and they run
our solar instead it's
order magnitude better than the mip
solvers they used
another nice application area which
might be interesting for people who work
on this
neural networks in particular binarized
neural networks
the issue with those is you get a lot of
refined constraints for the activation
functions
and those are really they're really
killing mip solvers because
when you relax them they get very
uninformative
but pseudo boolean solvers deal really
nicely with these refined constraints so
again we see like
just off-the-shelf order magnitude
performance and improvement compared to
mip okay
so this concludes my sales pitch
uh so i guess what i wanted to say is
pseudo boolean optimization
is uh it's a it's an expressive and
powerful framework but it's
close enough to sat that you can use all
your favorite ideas from sat
you can use ideas from mac sat in some
sense you know it can be argued that max
sat
and pseudo boolean optimization are just
two different ways of describing the
same problem
i believe that we have not we're very
far from
exploiting the full power of cutting
planes which is
exponentially stronger than what the
reasoning that we're using on the sat
side
and i also do believe that we could use
a lot of the insights from the mixed
integer linear programming
um literature um
and there are certainly uh i mean we're
not
where we would like to be in terms of
performance because of course we would
like to beat
the competition all of them including
the whip solars and we don't there are a
lot of
interesting challenges for how to design
the algorithms also efficient
implementation is a huge
uh challenge like a question like
how to propagate pseudo boolean
constraints is much more costly than
propagating clauses
and this is really slowing down solvers
also different reasoning methods
we just don't understand them as well as
we understand the resolution-proof
system underlying cdcl
but we already know that there are
applications where off-the-shelf
cutting planes based solvers are beating
the competition so
if you're looking at for instance you
know binarized neural networks or
something maybe
you should take a look at a
pseudo-boolean solver and see if it can
do some anything for you
so that's it
thank you jacob
so i'll take the first question so for
resolution is a is a perfect fit for
for a for cdcl because we know that if
you have a set of clauses
and you want to eliminate a variable
then you need to use
what you do is exactly resolution so
resolution
is equivalent to quantify quantify
elimination variable elimination
what is the corresponding statement if i
have a bunch of pseudo
pseudo boolean constraints i want to do
variable elimination
do we have the same kind of a theorem
that would give us the same result that
do we have an algorithm it has given us
an algorithm to eliminate variables
cutting planes saturations division and
saturation
i'm not sure i mean
my question clear
i have a set of suitable and constraints
and i want to eliminate the variable
and get the exist x such that
a set of wooden unconscious i want can i
represent it for example by set of
surubulan constraints even is the
projection
through the boolean i suppose so but
i've never seen the theorem they would
state what exactly is the projection
operation
i mean it i i think the answer is yes
but i'm not sure it's very interesting
like i mean it's definitely a complete
method right so you can you can
like eliminate in something like i think
you could do
like the analog of davis putnam
resolution
but i haven't thought about it in that
way and i don't know
i i i'm afraid i might not have a good
answer i mean maybe someone from the
audience would have a good answer
so this is a theoretical result because
it's important because it tells us that
the right thing you need to do when you
have a conflict
is to generate the conflict clause
and it is the resolution so give us also
a tight connection
between what cdcl does and you know we
have a theorem that connects
directly to both complexity okay we said
it generates
basically uh if you have cdcl plus
restart that gives you
uh it fails the resolution proof is
going to be of linear
of size linear or same size essentially
is the search tree
do we have the same kind of theoretical
uh foundations here
to some extent yes to some extent i mean
it's definitely the case that if you
look at what the sudobuna soldiers are
doing they will spit out
cutting planes proofs in exactly the
same way as a cdcl solver produces a
resolution proof
and this is a complete method so one big
difference
is that for for cdcl we have the
theoretical result
saying that assuming that your
heuristics are somehow magically optimal
then conflict-driven close learning with
restarts
is never more than polynomially worse
than resolution
so cdcl searches efficiently for
resolution proofs
this is false in a pseudo-boolean
setting
we are not searching efficiently for
coming planes proofs thank you
other questions are there any questions
on the charts
let me check the chat
yeah i have one yeah um so so this
mip you see they did it it looks to me
like look ahead right like the thing
what magain was explaining
you spend lots of time in every in the
search node and the of course your pb
silver does the opposite it's more like
city cell so the obvious question is of
course like just do what we did right
with this cube being conquered but for
pb no but and related to that are there
incremental pb servers because this is
something where
we need to for this cube and conquer
actually
you mean increment um
[Music]
i think that the the answer is that all
that
needs to be done in that setting could
be done but maybe it isn't as well
developed in the sense of having a
standard library or api for how to do
this and this is probably something that
we should do
um but yeah i think it's interesting to
note
like the parallels with marine stock i
was as i was listening to it
it's it's very similar in philosophy
but it's slightly different
in the so so one thing that i mean also
mip solvers would have this kind of
thing where they
probe variables and collect statistics i
think they call this strong branching
except that they actually consider this
to be too expensive i think so they do
this
strong branching at the start but then
when you've been running for a while
they collect statistics of how how this
branching
worked out and based on this
they make estimates of what's going to
happen in the future and this is
something that they call pseudo costs
so this is like an interesting question
whether you would do look ahead solving
and not
not do full probing but sort of do
intelligent guesses based on how things
have been performing previously that
would be a
porting mip techniques into look ahead
if but i don't know how
expensive the look ahead step is and
then another thing that
is nice i mean i think there's a lot of
questions to explore
at the interface of pseudo boolean
solving and mip solving but the fact
that you can
when you find the solution but it's
like you relax the problem you find a
rational solution that you can add a new
cut
which is a sound constraint
that cuts away this rational solution
and so
tightens your polytope this is important
and this we see that as i showed in some
of the experiments that this can really
improve
um this can really improve performance
another thing that can improve
performance is
when we're somewhere in the middle of
the search and we're asking the lp
solver
so the pseudo boolean server cannot see
the contradiction
but the residual lp is already
infeasible
in that case a mip solver can help us by
seeing
a that it is infeasible and b by farkas
lama it returns a conflict constraint so
that we can like
you know fast forward the conflict
analysis and this turns out to be these
constraints are apparently like super
useful
um so but it's an interesting question
yeah i don't know your experiments look
like you would import like a mip
technology into pb silver right but this
turns it around right so you would use a
pb a mip approach and then one point
switch to bb
that's what i'm asking yeah that that's
uh i i yeah that's interesting um i
think uh
so one problem has been to explain how
sudobu
conflict analysis works and the fact
that it is exponentially more powerful
this is somehow a message that is hard
to get across
but i think it's slowly sinking in and
that
it's more like i think there are people
on the mip side that would
like to do sudo boolean conflict
analysis but the question is whether it
will happen
because there's you know i mean there's
so many interesting questions to
pursue but yeah that's definitely like
taking
what we have done is is is like the the
mips the pb solver is clearly the master
and the lp solver is the slave you could
turn this relationship around and let
the conflict analysis be the slave
um yeah this is definitely something
that i'd like to do
miguel do you have a question
so this is this approach similar to sat
modulo integer linear arithmetic in the
smt setting yes and no
i think it's stronger in the sense
that since we're
operating on the linear constraint i
think in an smt setting you would be
restricted to deriving
facts that you can express in the
variables that you have
right you have variables that mean
certain things
and you can derive facts about those but
now when we're massaging our linear
constraints
will generate tons and tons of new
linear constraints
so like in an smt setting this would
correspond to i guess
you know generating a lot of extension
variables
which i don't think the smt solvers do
so in that sense i think it's slightly
orthogonal
thomas do you have a question if someone
decides to encode
a given pseudo-boolean formula into cnf
is there any known worst case upper
bounds regarding space there are lots of
results on
on how to do this yeah i mean you can do
it efficiently
there are two parameters that you trade
off the encoding size and the
propagation strength
and this has i mean there's a this is a
research area
and in the tutorial i have like some
some references for this
but but there's still room for like the
theoretical results don't
perfectly match what people actually use
in practice and there's probably room
for improvement
um any last question
sibila asks regarding back jumping with
chronological back
tracking similar to chronological cdcl
works not
jump to any asserting level uh
in some sense yes so we we don't know in
sudo boolean solvers that we're back
jumping to the right level so in in some
sense
all the extra hacks needed to make cdcl
work in a chronological setting in some
sense
i would argue they are most of them are
already there in a pseudo boolean
setting because we already need to deal
with these problems
if that's an answer to the question
okay we got all the questions answered
thank you jacob i think
we had a great session on three
different approaches to non-cdc
survey so i will close the session and
we didn't even lose power
some of them must have optimized the
power appropriately
so close the session we'll see your
website all the speakers
and we'll see you all next week bye